all right so i'm gavin sinclair today
we're solving cubic equations
um overview of the talk
briefly on polynomials um
sort of numerical examples quick
information
on on cubics then we get into the
details
a bit of a summary because it will be
very difficult to
keep track i promise you this will be
difficult
and then we'll get into the history and
uh and that means
so like i say quick all right this is
too slow
quick slow quick
numerical examples there when we look at
the depressed cubics that'll be
algebraic
and then the history is whatever i
remember which should be
should be pretty good you'll be
disappointed if i don't get to that
so i will need to go quickly through
this stuff and the
article has all the details
i have to give credit to this book it's
a wonderful book i've only read two
chapters
um the first chapter was the basis for
this talk
now i read it i read that chapter about
a year ago
and i'm i'm worried what i might end up
doing if i read more
so i was not expecting to encounter
cubic equations when i picked up a book
about complex numbers but that was in
chapter one
uh okay so just to put cubic equations
in context let's have a look at
polynomials so this is the easiest slide
right
x plus a equals zero so linear equations
are easily solved
quadratic equations have two solutions
um
and these have been known for a long
time all right so the ancient
uh well the sort of latter period
babylonians
and chinese both knew about completing
the square
around two to three hundred bc i think i
think euclid knew something about it
um yeah so quadratic equations have been
uh have been known for a long time
cubic equations well here's a cubic
formula
that's for one of the solutions
there's the second one and there's the
third one
you notice anything funny hi
now to the best of my knowledge there
are lots of cubic equations that have
only real solutions
but there you go
there's a there's one of the solutions
of the quartic equation
there's all of the solutions written in
a more schematic form
all right so it's quite amazing
and then quintic there is no formula now
how many people knew that
okay about half so there is no way
to write down a general solution
for that equation um
and i've known oh yes that's so good do
you know why gauss
couldn't find a solution for the clinton
equation
yes because he wasn't able
abel was the person the first to prove
that there is no solution no general
solution to the thinking
um now i i've known
for for many years that this had no
solution
but i only learnt this week that
it kind of does the fifth root of x is
the inverse of x to the five correct
if we just had some notation that was
the inverse of x to the five plus x
then we could write the solution to that
formula
make sense